[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
horned furred and face painted the
so-called q anon shaman pleads guilty in
the capital riots jacob chansley he
loves his country and the ex-prosecutor
of the yamada arbory case now charged
with violating her oath and obstructing
justice why one of the defendants left
her a voicemail hours after the shooting
jackie this is great did you call me as
soon as you possibly can plus charges
upgraded for kim potter in the shooting
death of dante wright the former police
officer now accused of first degree
manslaughter and later another r kelly
accuser takes the stand a woman telling
the jury she agreed to a 200 000
settlement with the r b singer after he
allegedly gave her herpes law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin one of the most recognizable
people from the capitol riots the man
dubbed the q and on shaman pleads guilty
law and crimes angenet levy is here with
details of jacob chansley's plea
agreement anjanet
brian jacob chansley pleaded guilty to
one count of obstruction of an official
proceeding his attorney says that he
actually renounced that q anon
conspiracy theory quite some time ago
now you may recall that chansley was the
man who was wearing horns and fur when
he entered the capital and the senate
chamber with others on january 6. his
attorney says he's been devoted to the
religious practice of shamanism for some
time hence the outfit now while chansley
gained attention for demanding organic
food behind bars his attorney says he
wants to be held accountable for his
actions and now realizes he committed a
crime he was found mentally competent
but an evaluation also found mental
health vulnerabilities his attorney
albert watkins took some time to speak
about the importance of treating people
with mental health issues
as a result of
being in
solitary confinement
since january 9
2021
i realized and watched as my client
declined
from a gentle
extraordinarily smart
kind man
into a
an individual who was clearly mentally
falling into the abyss
any health care provider
who does so much as clip toenails for a
living will tell you
that those with
mental health vulnerabilities of the
nature
that mr chansley is addressing
are not served
by
solitary solitary confinement but rather
the worst thing that can possibly be
done
is to place them in solitary confinement
indefinitely
now watkins went on to say that jacob
chansley was disappointed when president
trump did not pardon him before leaving
office he said that chansley is a navy
veteran who was thought he was doing
something patriotic back on january 6th
he also says that chan lee chansley
rather was not planning to overthrow the
government
with jacob chansley he loves his country
he was
in dc at the special instance and call
of the president in his heart
and in his mind he was helping
the president save the country
he was not alone
jacob chansley peacefully surrendered
jacob chansley did not have a plan
he was not an individual who was a
leader
albert watkins has asked that jacob
chansley be released from jail pending
sentencing he wants to move to the st
louis area where he could receive more
mental health treatment prosecutors are
objecting to that they say he's only
been in jail for eight months and under
the sentencing guidelines he faces
anywhere between 44 and 60 months in
prison for that crime um so albert
watkins though said that under the plea
agreement he can argue for less time
behind bars than that brian
thanks anjeanette joining us today as
former prosecutor melbourne pearson and
terry austin melville the man formerly
known as the q anon shaman faces three
years in eight months to five years
that's the 44 and 60 months in prison
where do you think the judge will decide
how long you should stay in for
yeah i think that it's gonna fall
somewhere in the middle i think that it
won't be like on the
three years and eight months
kind of area i think it's gonna be more
around four four and a half years i
think that the judge is going to want to
give a significant sentence to send a
message that people just can't come and
desecrate the symbols of our democracies
you know desecrate our capital and that
you know you've got to respect the
outcome of an election right you may not
agree with it but you have to respect it
you can't take these types of actions so
i don't see him
departing underneath the guidelines to
give him less but i will say this i do
agree with the defense attorney that
solitary confinement should not be used
or if it has to be used must be used
sparingly because of the mental health
impact it has on everyone as a general
premise but i think his sentence is
going to be around four and a half years
or so i would agree terry do you see any
mitigating factors that may reduce uh
chansley's sentence
i think there are a number of mitigating
factors the first one is the psychiatric
evaluation that he had apparently he has
bipolar disorder and depression and that
evaluation was very similar to an
earlier evaluation that he had when he
was in the u.s navy the other issue
brian is i haven't seen any evidence
that he has a criminal record as you
heard his attorney said he surrendered
peacefully he didn't harm to our
knowledge any property or injure any
people and he's also disassociating
himself with q anon so i think for those
reasons there are a number of mitigating
factors interesting now anjanet why does
admiral watkins say chansley
did what he did
well he says that chansley is somebody
who was raised by a single mom and had a
rough childhood and he was under the
belief on january 6 that president trump
was being picked on as he had been in
his younger years uh watkins said that
chansley doesn't have a criminal record
you hear terry make reference to that
and he said that he is actually
extricating himself from that q anon
belief system and watkins says that's
really something that's been a process
he also says that chansley has been
cooperative with the authorities
interesting of course we'll keep eyes on
that case as the sentencing is set to
come up soon in this year we'll figure
out how many years or months he gets and
whether or not al watkins can reduce
that sentence as he says he might be
able to thank you everyone turning now
to more top legal news a jury has now
been selected in the highly anticipated
fraud trial of former theron ceo
elizabeth holmes
elizabeth holmes is facing 12 charges of
wire fraud and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud at our now defunct startup holmes
falsely promised that theranos developed
a blood test that only required a prick
of blood a jury of seven men five women
plus five alternates will hear the case
opening statements are set for next
wednesday she faces up to 20 years in
prison if convicted
still ahead on law and crime daily the
upgraded charges for the former police
officer accused of fatally shooting
dante wright but first a major update in
the ahmad armory case why the first
prosecutor assigned to handle the case
is now facing charges herself the
accusations next
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
welcome back one of the former
prosecutors of the ahmad armory case is
now finding herself on the other side of
the law the former district attorney is
facing charges of violating her oath and
obstructing justice
ahmad aubry was shot and killed while
out jogging on february 23 2020. three
defendants are now charged in the case
gregory mcmichael travis mcmichael and
william rhodey bryan but their charges
didn't come for months
georgia's attorney general now says the
local prosecutor at the time got in the
way on thursday a grand jury indicted
jackie johnson the former brunswick
district attorney she faces up to five
years in prison for violating her oath
of public office and up to 12 months for
obstructing and hindering a law
enforcement officer according to the
indictment johnson let her favor and
affection for gregory mcmichael stand in
the way of justice gregory mcmichael
worked for the da's office as an
investigator for more than 20 years at a
bond hearing last year prosecutors
played a voicemail mcmichael made to
johnson his former boss immediately
after the shooting
jackie this is great did you call me as
soon as you possibly can
and um need some advice right away
please call me as soon as you possibly
can
let's bring back former prosecutor
melville pearson and terry austin to
discuss the indictment of a former d.a
terry how important important is this
call between gregory mcmichael and
jackie johnson and making out this
violation of oath charge
it's a big deal if in fact the
prosecution can demonstrate that gregory
mcmichael asked for a favor and that
johnson responded to that favor it's
going to be a big problem for her
actually she handed the case off to this
other d.a and if she did that because
mcmichael asked her to do that that is
very serious and the family is claiming
that there was a cover-up the indictment
basically says the exact same thing that
there was a cover-up and the other issue
that the indictment lists is the fact
that she asked these enforcement
officers not to arrest travis the son
and gregory mcmichael could have asked
her to do that as well so she's facing
some serious charges if the prosecution
can actually demonstrate that and she's
going to have to ultimately testify
under oath and i guarantee you she will
be asked about that phone call
absolutely now melba violation of an
oath of office comes with a jail
sentence of one to five years could this
case affect how prosecutors pursue cases
in georgia or even the nation
absolutely this is going to have a
massive impact on prosecution around the
country the last major case of this uh
type of issue was around 2006 with mike
nyphon who was the elected prosecutor
handling the uh duke lacrosse sexual
assault case and he withheld exculpatory
evidence ended up getting a uh one day
in custody for contempt of court but
ended up being disbarred and of course
being removed from his position so now
this is and that was held up as the
ethics warning for all prosecutors at
the time so i think this case is going
to be that
benchmark moving forward of you don't
want to be like her so make sure that if
somebody calls you you immediately
document it and you make sure that you
handle the case properly and not try to
influence the outcome one way or the
other or influence the investigation in
an inappropriate manner like she did
here absolutely of course these are just
indictments we'll see as his case
progresses maybe it's a plea deal maybe
it's a trial but of course we'll keep
eyes on that development now to more top
legal news former police officer kim
potter is now facing a more serious
charge for the fatal shooting of dante
wright in minnesota
former brooklyn center police officer
kim potter is now charged with
first-degree manslaughter for the death
of dante wright the 20-year-old black
man who was shot during a traffic stop
last year during the altercation potter
is heard on body cam video telling
wright i'm going to taser you but she
instead pulled out her gun and fired a
bullet the young man took off crashing
his car and died potter was originally
charged with second-degree manslaughter
that's now been upgraded to first degree
meaning the former police officer could
face up to five more years in prison
she's set to stand trial in november and
cameras won't be allowed in
disappointing wright's family
you know we have a community that wants
transparency wants to see what's going
on and dante writes a killing by kim
potter is one of the most important
police issues going on in our country
right now and i think the public you
know should see what's happening in that
trial so we're obviously disappointed
that they can't
coming up on law and crime daily an isis
terrorist is pleading guilty to
beheading american citizens how much
time he'll spend in prison
plus a secret hearing in the doomsday
duo case why was chad davil in court for
a sealed hearing while laurie valodevo's
attorney were an open court for her
those cases and more ahead
[Music]
welcome back a former isis terrorist is
now on u.s soil is pleading guilty to
the beheadings of american citizens
former british citizen alexander cote
was part of the isis guards known as the
beatles the group is believed to be tied
to dozens of kidnappings and responsible
for the deaths of at least four
americans the u.s had to agree not to
seek the death penalty in exchange for
the men's extradition kute pled guilty
to eight charges in connection to the
deaths of four u.s hostages for a
mandatory minimum sentence of life
without parole at a press conference
last year the doj paused to remember the
victims and shared their stories
james foley was a print and video
journalist who was covering the civil
war in syria
he had previously served as a conflict
zone correspondent in iraq and then in
libya
james was a former elementary school
teacher steven sotloff was a journalist
who covered the middle east and was in
syria reporting on the refugee crisis
according to a longtime friend he was
drawn to the region to quote give a
voice to the people who didn't have one
close quote stephen was the grandson of
holocaust survivors who inspired him to
be that voice peter kasich was in syria
working for a humanitarian organization
that he founded to deliver food and
medical aid to the refugees
he had previously served as an elite
airborne ranger in the u.s army which
included service in iraq kayla mueller
was a humanitarian aid worker and human
rights activist who inspired by her
faith
devoted much of her young life to
serving those in need both at home
and abroad
as president trump shared during his
2020 state of the union address the
american warriors who conducted the
military operation
that resulted in the death of isis
leader abu bakr al-baghdadi
we're in so inspired by kayla that they
named the mission
task force 814 a reference to august
14th kayla's birthday
turning now to oklahoma where the
sheriff of tulsa says he's still haunted
by the murder of a ten-year-old girl the
sheriff spoke to our own sean
stix-larkins on the latest episode of
the podcast cocktails and cocktails
so unfortunately um
one day she starts walking and
just across the street was an individual
that uh
you know turned about to be out one of
one of everybody's nightmare he's he's
the devil he sees her coming and
fixates on her and
starts to formulate a plan that if she
walks back around he was going to throw
a ball
with his puppy
and her direction get her to pick the
ball up
bring it over closer and closer to his
puppy and he ultimately did that he she
comes around again
she brings it he keeps dragging her
slowly in she's not realizing it and as
soon as he gets her close to his front
door he punches her out and drags her
into his house where
and i'm not gonna go into details it was
the worst confession i've ever taken uh
it still sends chills down my spine but
he basically tortured and and raped her
and then ultimately dumped her body
when we come back the shocking new
accusation against r kelly how much a
singer allegedly paid one woman he's
accused of spreading herpes to our legal
analysis next
[Music]
welcome back unusual court filings in
the doomsday cult duo case are now
raising eyebrows it appears chad davao
had a closed hearing the same day his
wife laurie valodebel had a hearing over
her competency
chad and lori davil are charged in the
murders of lori's two children j.j valo
and tyler ryan along with the murder of
chad's first wife tammy daybell
prosecutors say they plan to seek the
death penalty for chad if he's convicted
lori's case is on hold for now in the
meantime her attorney mark means filed a
motion to intervene in chad day bell's
case generally motion to intervene are
only filed in civil cases when
non-parties want to join and assert
their rights it's not clear why means
filed this motion but the state claims
the motion is meritless meanwhile the
state filed a motion regarding chad
dabel's attorney john pryor the court
determined that the two motions are
interrelated and that both should be
heard under seal to protect the
interests of both parties we'll keep you
updated as these cases progress
now to ohio where a man is accused of
setting three fires in his neighborhood
stanley ford is on trial for allegedly
starting three fires that resulted in
the deaths of nine people including an
entire family with children all under
the age of 15. so far neighbors and
friends of the victims have taken the
stand to talk about ford's relationship
with his neighbors most of them saying
that he had problems with lindell lewis
the owner of the first home the fire
investigator and medical examiner both
took the stand to talk about how the
fire was started and what the cause of
death was for the first two victims
did you rely on that
determination by the arson investigator
that it wasn't intentionally set fire to
come to a determination for lindell
lewis yes sir i did and so you
um made a determination as to conor's
the manner of death for mr lewis yes i
did and what was that the cause of death
was soot and smoke inhalation the manner
of death was homicide and how injury
occurred is breathed in smoke from an
intentionally set house fire
and in the federal sex trafficking trial
of r kelly another woman came forward
saying the singer gave her herpes
this woman who identified herself as
kate testified that she met the i
believe i can fly singer in 2001 and
that he gave her herpes when she was 27
making her the third woman to testify
that r kelly gave them herpes she
testified she was very concerned about
stds and when she asked him to use a
condom he just said no she also
testified that in 2004 r kelly settled a
lawsuit with her agreeing to give her
200 000 after contracting herpes the
defense used kate to undercut the
prosecution's argument that kelly gave
his girlfriends harsh rules to follow
she was able to go
to and from the bathroom and didn't have
to wait long periods of times for him
kelly treated her different and she even
helped him write down lyrics prosecutors
are expected to arrest their case in
about two weeks
melba kate is not an accuser but she is
getting more testimony that corroborates
what the accusers testify to i don't
think they're anywhere close to this but
does the government have to consider it
being a possible appeal for overly
prejudicial testimony
i think that that's definitely something
to think about that it has to be in the
prosecution's mind we're definitely not
there yet everything that is being
presented is being was relevant is
really going towards showing the pattern
and practice that he had of the way that
he abused the women of course it was
going to look differently depending on
the victim but there were some common
threads i know there's a lot of concern
especially after what happened with bill
cosby but just to really distinguish
that there were other issues in the bill
cosby case on top of the number of
people that were testifying that were
not directly tied to the case so here i
think all of them have a clear nexus to
r kelly so i think the prosecution is
still in a good place but they need to
just keep an eye on that to be mindful
for appeal purposes absolutely terry the
prosecution inspector to rest the week
of september 13th what do you think is
left to prove the rico and man act
charges
i think the prosecution has done a great
job so far establishing both rico and
and crimes under the manned act they've
established that there is an enterprise
and that that enterprise
supported his sexual activity so maybe
some more to underscore but that's it
absolutely i agree there thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you